[Musique] La
cible vient de faire une gauche, ne perdez pas une pour
vous ici maintenant, nous avons des voitures qui volent
là-bas quand j'ai vu le renversé, cela
m'a juste rappelé comment cette franchise propose
de nouvelles idées et ça me souffle avec
la bête  cette voiture a l'air super cool
je suis une guerre de véhicules il y a un tout
autre niveau
je suis une voiture quelque chose avec laquelle Ennis et moi nous
avons joué avec Justin a dit que je
veux quelque chose qui va rouler de front
dans un véhicule et lancer  lui dans les airs,
le design est vraiment venu de Shaw est
quelqu'un qui ira au
milieu de la tempête et démolira
tout sur son passage
cette voiture est probablement la voiture la plus
exigeante en main-d'œuvre que nous ayons, elle est
essentiellement construite à partir de zéro, elle est à
peu près basée sur  une voiture de formule 1 c'est
très bas au sol d'énormes pneus la
chose la plus bruyante que j'aie jamais entendue comme
avoir un t-rex ouvrir la bouche juste
derrière un gros gros morceau d'un moteur huit
cylindres qui produit environ 500
chevaux il est également équipé d'un
arrière  -la roue  direction qui est actionnée à
partir d'ici, nous pouvons tourner ces roues à
gauche tourner ses roues à droite, nous inversons la
direction 180 360 fois ici opérait
la pression qui monte et qui
permet aux voitures de passer par-dessus
et garde le conducteur plus en sécurité
belle vue  toutes ces choses renverser
cinq voitures de police en 15 secondes de
conduite sont extraordinaires, il n'y a pas
beaucoup de place à l'erreur, ce qui témoigne
du fait que nous poussons l'enveloppe aussi loin que
possible,
il s'est vendu il y a très longtemps, mais nous devons
bien travailler ensemble de la même manière.  rappelez-vous de
faire tasin nous avons construit une petite rampe de tuyaux
vers les voitures à bascule et j'ai dit eh bien
essayons simplement et nous avons été surpris
parce que cette voiture à bascule fait vraiment basculer la zone
pour ces voitures, donc les images du
film sont en fait deux pilotes qui vont de
front avec  les uns les autres et c'est vraiment
arrivé pour un
timing réel mais le plus précis, mes lignes doivent être
à quelques centimètres de chaque côté si
nous nous trompons, la voiture va retourner Jason a
vu les résultats de ce que nous avons pu
faire un  d va je veux que vous en ajoutiez plus tirez
ces voitures avec plus de voitures de
police écrasent plus de voitures de police lorsque vous voyez une
voiture venir ou voler dans les airs et
soyez assuré que la voiture dégringole et
vole dans les airs cette partie
ne vous est jamais vue '  Je vais voir un
carnage de véhicules à sensations fortes J'adore la voiture à bascule Je
pense que c'est ce qui maintient les gens dans leur
siège et se demande quel type de voiture
ils vont avoir
et nous sommes toujours surprenants